how's it goin everybody it's Lauren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and the MCU and today
we have to talk about the future of
Black Widow which sounds very very weird
considering the fact that she died in a
vendor's endgame however with the Black
Widow movie coming out now on November
6th and since the announcement of the
Black Widow movie after Avengers and
game many people are wondering if there
are going to be more Black Widow films
that take place before she dies after
all many people love Black Widow and
we've all been waiting for a solo film
for her for a very long time and now it
seems that everybody wants more of Black
Widow after her solo film and as it
turns out there could be more films for
Black Widow after her original solo film
there have been rumors for a while that
there could actually be some sort of a
trilogy now these are just rumors but
there is a possibility that there could
be more films including a Secret
Avengers
film and this could be set up at the
very end of Black Widow and I'm going to
dive into everything that we know about
this including a possible Secret
Avengers movie if you're new be sure to
subscribe notifications turned on so you
can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
so there's been talks about another
black widow movie for a while
it's just talked but The Closer that we
get to Black Widow coming out the more
it seems like there could be another
movie it's definitely a possibility
considering the fact that we definitely
know how Black Widow is going to end and
based off of everything that we know
about the Black Widow movie it does set
up The Secret Avengers which we do know
were formed before the events of
Avengers infinity war so right now
here's everything that we know about the
Black Widow film that leads up to the
Secret Avengers and if you are trying to
avoid any and all spoilers you should
probably click away now if you're still
with me we know that the film is
primarily going to be about Black Widow
and her so-called family taking down the
Red Room and taskmaster now it's already
been revealed that Ray Winstone is going
to be playing Jarek off a Russian
mobster who is running the Red Room now
if that name sounds familiar it's
probably because you heard it and
first Avengers film when Loki is talking
to Black Widow she says that she has red
in her ledger and she needs to wipe it
clean but Loki says can you get rid of
that much red and then he mentioned some
events and one of those events was Drake
Huff's daughter can he based off of what
we know and what we've learned Drake off
wants Black Widow alive so he can get
revenge for his daughter that apparently
Natasha killed Natasha
apparently did not mean to kill his
daughter she was actually going for him
and she found out that his daughter was
with him but apparently by the time that
she found out the daughter was with him
the bomb was already placed and the
Russians made it explode so throughout
the movie taskmaster will be trying to
retrieve Natasha for Drake off and
eventually of course at the end the Red
Room will be taken down but there is a
key element to this movie that not too
many people think is that important and
that is Thunderbolt Ross Thunderbolt
Ross was responsible for the sokovia
accords and at first Black Widow was for
them but then we know how that ended she
ended up helping Bucky escape in Captain
America Civil War however after the
airport battle in civil war she wasn't
captured unlike some of the other
vendors like ant-man Wanda Hawkeye Sam
she went away on her own she did not go
with Captain America and Bucky she ran
away and now we know where and whom she
ran away too according to a leak that
we've gotten that has been proved to be
legitimate Natasha
leaves and hides in Cleveland whilst
hiding in Cleveland another black widow
comes and attacks her but Natasha
manages to kill her and steal her
communicator she goes and visits her old
friend Mason who's an ex SHIELD agent
and helps her decrypt the communicator
there it is revealed that her sister
Yelena is being targeted so she tracks
down her sister and goes to Budapest to
an old Red Room safehouse but secretly
the entire time secretary Ross and his
men are tracking her so of course from
there the whole events of Black Widow
are going to play out natasha is going
to get with Elena and eventually Alexi
and Melina and they'll take down the Red
Room but at the end of the film
according to this leak secretary Ross is
going to show up and
and his men are going to take Natasha in
natin Yelena have a tearful farewell and
Yelena leaves with some other black
widows to help them back in the world
NAT stays behind and is arrested by Ross
and taken back to New York City but she
is then rescued by Hawkeye Hawkeye helps
break her out and gets her in contact
with the Secret Avengers now we know who
the Secret Avengers art it's Captain
America Sam and then of course Black
Widow and this was actually revealed to
us in the Avengers infinity war prelude
comics reveals that have the potential
to be explored further in the MCU
especially if they go down the route of
a secret Avengers film or perhaps even a
Disney Plus series but in the Avengers
prelude comic gets revealed just as it
is at the end of Captain America Civil
War that captain shows up to the prison
and he breaks out all of the current
Avengers ant-man Wanda Hawkeye and Sam
Hawkeye says that it's time for him to
retire and captain says understood go
back home and be with your family but
remember what was revealed in Avengers
infinity war
Hawkeye ends up taking a plea deal with
the government the same goes for Scott
Lang this is so they can be with their
families
that means Hawkeye breaks Natasha out of
whatever prison she's being held in in
between him being broken out and him
taking a plea deal and this is when
Captain America Sam and Natasha are
going to get together to form the secret
Avengers now in the prelude comics it
does show the secret Avengers together
and it's very short-lived but it does
show them tackling some missions at one
point Sam even asked Captain America if
he wants to call in Tony for some help
but Captain America says that they're
fine but this reveals that there's
actually quite a lot that happened in
between Captain America Civil War and
Avengers infinity war and this is where
the secret Avengers film could come in
because clearly there's a lot that
happened that we don't know about but
there are some things that are very very
interesting that lead me to believe that
there could be a secret Avengers either
Disney Plus show or movie for starters
Captain America Black Widow and Falcon
they all report to Nick Fury and Maria
hill this is how it was in The Secret
Avengers comics but it's also how it was
and the infinity war prelude so shield
or at least Maria Hill and Nick Fury
have been up to a lot too but the most
interesting part is the team of The
Secret Avengers and
comics the team in the comics actually
lines up with all of the heroes that are
going to be headed to the MCU very soon
for example moon night and shang-chi are
both a part of The Secret Avengers team
in the comics and of course we know that
shang-chi and The Legend of the tin
rings is going to be coming in phase
four and Moon Knight has been officially
announced and confirmed by Disney to be
coming to Disney Plus so it does seem
like something could be set up here to
establish the introduction of some new
characters into the MCU and the Secret
Avengers especially if they want to do
another black widow film this would be
where they would go because this black
would a film we know is going to dive a
little bit into her origins and then
it's going to cover the entirety between
the events of Captain America Civil War
and the events that were revealed in the
infinity war prelude comic which are the
events of The Secret Avengers so this is
certainly the story they would go about
because that's where we would be up to
with the Black Widow storyline and not
to mention it could also introduce the
other Secret Avengers that will be
coming to the MCU as well but would you
like to see another black with a movie
after her solo film and if so would you
like it to be a secret Avengers film let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to stay up-to-date
on everything relating to the MCU